effectivement analyse avec l'expert
michel nadeau et l'expérience transports
daniel bord de l'eau experts en
gouvernance michel nadeau ancien vice
président de la caisse de dépôt et
guelma bonsoir messieurs soir bonsoir
monsieur nadeau d'abord est ce que c'est
une bonne transaction
il l'a bien le dira je pense que pour
bombardier bombardier
il ne lui restait que les avions
d'affaires et que bombardier transport
comme actif
il appelle des zones dette de 10
milliards de dollars et les la division
de bombardier transport avait beaucoup
de problèmes
- les trois quatre dernières années un
train ces projets sont un wagon des
locomotives c'est beaucoup de logiciels
50 % du prix d'un train ses services et
les logiciels
le reste c'est vraiment le matériel
roulant dont et de ce côté là donc bon
dans tes transports présentaient des
problèmes et n'a porté plus le cash-flow
république
on avait acheté bombardier transport
parce qu'on disait ça va donner 4 500
millions ça vaut stabiliser les revenus
claireaux nautiques sont plutôt qu à
hauteur d'homme et unis depuis trois
quatre ans ça ne faisait plus le travail
dont l'avant comme une compagnie qui
compagnie allemande siège social à
berlette ce n'était plus perçu comme
étant stratégique pour la direction
bombardier qui veut jouer la carte héros
de type bombardier transport avait des
problèmes et comment un secteur très
concurrentiel ça n'allait pas bien pour
bombarder temps sinon ça n'est pas bien
parce qu'en fait ça commence et que le
train de banlieue de paris le francilien
ya quelques années un petit problème
comme monsieur nadeau il disait les
porte qui s'ouvrait pas à cause d'un
système informatique défectueux s'est
pris trois ans pour corriger le problème
et il y avait des pénalités de prévu
d'un contre ça a coûté plus de 300
millions à bombardier en pénalité juste
pour ce contrôle a alors ce après ça
s'est multiplié il ya eu new york ou
toronto il ya eu la suisse et
l'allemagne ainsi de suite
bombardier a jamais réussi à contrôler
cette compagnie là quand même qu'alstom
aujourd'hui dans le communiqué disait
qu'elle allait rétablir certains
standards de qualité justement à partir
de maintenant est ce que bombardier fait
bien de vendre la section transport les
trains plus
les avions d'affaires monsieur bellemare
a dit qu'il était clair qu'il n'allait
pas vendre nous appelons à faire
je pense que les avions d'affaires c'est
une carte où bombardier établi sa marque
la marque bombardier d'un monde
aéronautique
si sur tous les avions d'après donc je
pense qu'ils ont un avantage que c'est
pas une petite compagnie c'est 5
milliards et demi
18 mai l'emploi dont les deux tiers sont
à montréal toute la recherche dans le
monde et avions d'après ce faire partir
de montréal
la marge est bonne c'est pour ça or donc
c'est internet commun 15 milliards 2
années production donc sur physique que
bombardier avions d'affaires et est un
actif qu'un bon potentiel évidemment
cela conjoncture c'est devaient se
détériorer
peut-être qu'ils auraient des acheteurs
mais encore une fois les acheteurs il
faut presque est milliardaire pour se
payer le gros bol set mais c'est ça qui
coûte 90 80 millions 1 15 million lors
donc des cas ce contexte là ses preuves
à la meilleure carte que bombardier
devait conserver que je pense
qu'effectivement textron ne lâchera pas
on va essayer durera 3 4 ans la dette
baisser à 4 milliards 3 4 milliards lots
de gérer cette dette là avec les profits
des des avions d'affaires
mais il ya quand même des risques parce
que il ya une concurrence qui se
développe dans le secteur des avions
d'affaires
il ya un surplus d'offre également alors
là si on regarde les challengers deux
modèles 3,50 et 7,50 sont fabriqués de
saint orens ce sont de vieux avions qui
descendent du challenger de deux
canadairs il ya longtemps
alors c'est à lui en ont besoin d'être
renouvelé en profondeur et ça ça va
demander de l'argent
est ce que bombardier va en avoir assez
c'est pas clair les globaux ça vaut bien
les globaux sont fabriqués à toronto
mais la finition intérieure se fait à
montréal
eux ils ont été modernisées
il ya un an l'an dernier et ils peuvent
soutenir la concurrence la concurrence
justement et je vous ramène sur les
trains sur le bombardier transport est
ce que vous pensez daniel que les
autorités de la concurrence en europe
vont approuver la transaction alstom
bombardier
il semble que c'est moins problématique
qu'avec sim ce parce que son que les
deux compagnies bombardier alstom sont
plus complémentaires que siemens avec
siemens dans certains domaines notamment
dans le secteur des communications et de
la signalisation
le groupe aurait contrôlé près de 100%
de du marché dans certaines régions
d'europe
là avec bombardier c'est pas un problème
bombardier pas très fort en
signalisation et ils sont plutôt
complémentaires
alors donc ça devrait passer mieux nous
dit on les effets au québec je veux
parler des effets au québec avec vous
michel nadeau qui on va le voir dans le
tableau parce que alstom prend des
engagements d'établir un siège pour les
amériques d'alstom de développer un
centre d analyse et la caisse de dépôt
disait dans son communiqué aujourd'hui
que l'entreprise s'engage également à
une expansion à la pocatière est
également assurée d'être assis est-ce
qu'on en sort absolument gagnant du
break sur 10 éprouve - des employés ce
qui me fait pas c'est qu'elle sommes une
très belle usine a en elle dans l'état
de new york 7 125 employés et qui est
l'usiné où sortent beaucoup de degrés
ils ont aussi un site en californie
or dans ce contexte là moi il ya des
cadres d'alstom qui m'ont téléphoné
aujourd'hui qui m'ont dit nous user nous
y performent bien
hier onze usines d'alstom aux états unis
2400 employés cesse à dompter ce
contexte là c'est poids acquis en
partant quand vous avez 10 8% sur
conseil d'administration d'une
entreprise
évidemment on vous écoute le président
peut être gentil avec vous de commerce
agréable cetera
il pense à ces rémunérations sur body
mais il donne ma peau - qui à 81 2% des
actionnaires qui ont pas su si dd
les installations de la compagnie au
québec donc si les installations de la
compagnie à la pocatière et le centre
administratif à saint bruno
ça va mais si c'est assez concurrentiels
monsieur dont on devait trouver que
c'est 20 et 30 35 % moins chers
fabriqués aux états unis pour dans les
installations d'alstom s'avère très
difficile de maintenir la pression pour
dire un gars au québec la caisse de
dépôts devient le premier actionnaire
d'alstom 18% du capital est une bonne
nouvelle pour le volet je pense
qu'alstom ne jamais été une gros à grand
performant un grand performant mais ils
sont quand même dans le secteur très
porteur
le transport collectif il a grande
question pour elle ce tome est ce que le
temps du trait est arrivé en amérique
l'amérique c'est le monde de
l'automobile individuelle mais là avec
le débat sur l'environnement
peut-être que les gens d'alstom
plusieurs mozilla on veut percer le
damné marche amic c'est vrai c'est 25 %
de leurs ventes actuelles garder les
chiffres fournis aujourd'hui par alstom
qui affirme que la croissance justement
et les leurs dans le trafic de passagers
et dans les équipements ferroviaires de
3 à 5% par année de 2015 à 2025 les
équipements ferroviaires croissance
prévue de 3 % par année de 2021 2023
ouais effectivement quand on regarde aux
etats-unis dans certaines régions la
californie new york
la fluorine il ya une volonté d'avoir
des système ferroviaire efficace rapide
des tgv ya des projets de tgv qui sont
en chantier depuis des années et le
gouvernement actuel à washington est
personnellement mais il ya une volonté
populaire alors il ya une chance que ça
se réalise quand même la dernière levée
de jamie de tesla seront toujours
présents pour alain
la dernière fois qu alain bellemare nous
a accordé une entrevue c'était en
novembre 2016 rdi économie voici ce
qu'il disait
je pense que ce qui est important de
réaliser que bombardier nous sur le bar
de la fayette en 2015 et c'était c'est
important pour nous de réduire notre
structure de coûts de sorte à s'assurer
le succès à long terme de l'entreprise
il disait sans 2015 parlait qu'on était
sur le bord de la fillette en 2015
nous sommes en 2020
bilan des courses ou sans nation n'avait
pas vendu transports on serait sur le
bord de la faillite au début de 2021
résister oui ou non le plaisir énorme à
sion partie réussie n'a pas réussi non
il n'a pas réussi à le liquider mais la
dette s'est maintenue et c'est écrit
évidemment en grande partie à cause de
la transaction avec la caisse
j'ai fait une grande sortie mot disant
il faut aller négocier avec ces vautours
qui a 8 % heures pour sa exploite
bombardier les gens de mon mari m'a
appelé au calme après midi et on
s'inquiète pour sa à la caisse de dépôt
les bretons est ici saute à mourir un
rendement composé de caisse pour sa part
année depuis trois ans ça veut dire 50 %
de rendement 3 à payer à la caisse
or soyez évidemment ces déclins naulleau
rompu ce sera des actions d'alstom deux
nuls mais par contre 6 en 2014 2013
on avait décidé de vin bombardier
transport il y avait paraît-il
développeurs d'adobe d'achat à 8,9
milliards
à ce moment là la dette de bombardier
devait être autour de 7 milliards
bombardier aurait pu limiter toute sa
dette avec l'argent dans les transports
il aurait eu un ou deux milliards dans
leur poche
il aurait pu finir l'industrialisation
du cseries et à ce moment là on aurait
peut-être mis au monde un vrai
concurrent pour boeing et airbus